io li ho tutti a
tutti i miei non è giusto vitale a tutti
i pop hit sapete perché beh se non lo
sapete andate a vedere la scorsa
challenge quella in cui gli ho fatto uno
scherzo ho sostituito ipocrita bendata è
andata a finire male ma in questa
nuovissima challenge siccome avete
lasciato i 10 mila mi piace in questa
nuova challenge proverò a riprendermi un
sacco di pop hit è sempre un bel mi
piace se anche questo video raggiunge i
10 mila richieste sarà un'altra
challenge propri creta challenge copit
estrema proverò a riprendermi tutti i
miei fan
via allora anita io come puoi vedere o
tutti hip hop ixquick topic mi offre io
purtroppo ho perso tutti i pop hit marzo
è uscito a comprare nuovi pop
[Applauso]
hip hop it per questa quindi che cosa mi
offri per questa paparella viviamo
vediamo che cosa o chi allora per la
paperella ti offro un cupcake colorato
abbia le ragazze lo offro comunque è una
coccinella che fu arriva con paparella
il milan croci nella è molto carina non
è una epistola questi nella rosa bazzi
come la paperella e rara ne voglio il
pil allora aggiungo e questa è l'ultima
offerta era attenzione indici maison e
quindi adesso ai tre hopit per un po
pitt paperella del pil
aveva pronto a rifiutare
mi dispiace per te hai perso troppo
pizzo che rimangono un bel marco minuti
ho fatto questa cappella raro è
carinissima bellissima peggio perché
eto'o e al test secondo round
l'uomo subito con un po il quid gigante
poi ti offro il mio compito preferito a
cuba nera poi abbiamo anche ma erlino
sta assistendo alla challenge sta
facendo dal giudice basita da trent'anni
poi abbiamo il pop isolato e il pop il
topolino e mi minore topolino ma non c è
vero ti
offro bocchettoni con un po pittore
tagliabile non era il solare e un po
liberto rendendo la bile ho detto che
cosa mi offre in cambio guarda la tv
piste offerto wow in effetti se
prendessi tutti questi pop hit avrei
nuovamente tantissimi pop hit per me
quindi devono offrire qualcosa che
quindi
vita ha detto che adori l'arcobaleno
sì qui sotto eccola con l'arcobaleno
guarda che cosa ti offro un po pitt
molto raro bello davvero
la balena
arcobaleno ma è blu ma è bellissima che
le pinne la bocca e super carina allora
siccome questo è un po più ferraro
accetti l'arco e la balena blu in cambio
di questi pop hit ma qui in tu mi
vorreste offrire solo un po pit per
tutti questi team a è rara la balena blu
da iazzetta
no
e va bene che offre un altro pupi tra
roma e l'ultimo ti offro l'arco pinguino
dopo l'arcobaleno abbiamo i pingui york
dal m bellissimo non puoi non accettare
questa offerta due pop hit orari balenae
pinguino per quei topi tutta e che fai
cassetti effettivamente l'arco pinguino
cento e mi ha accettato
finalmente sta ricominciando formi un
bottino di momento
soprattutto il compito gigante
terzo round ti offro un altro po peter
raro che ho comprato
il tiro zoro che calino oltre gelato
so che a te piacciono i dinosauri quindi
non puoi non accettare e bellissimo
anche gli occhi naso e corno icsa mi
offrì per questo dinosaur etto
sauro wow è bellissimo per questo
dinosauro io offro anzi facciamo uno
scambio ti offro un t rex arcobaleno e
ti offre una fragola non è abbastanza
di più ma stiamo scambiando un dinosauro
però di rosa proprio una fragola e come
ultimo pop hit e un po anche un gattino
il pop hit del gattino era uno dei miei
po più preferiti
però vorrei più poco it
e va bene
[Musica]
adesso io ti offro un banchetto guardate
caria
il granchietto e diritti forte
[Applauso]
a
me rimane solo la batteria di prima che
hai rifiutato ma quella che carina da e
bellissima accettata non lo so io ti sto
sempre offrendo tanti pochi solo uno ma
qui ferrara dai sub carina thai accetta
la motoria credo di sì dell'egeo va a
fondo
penso che galleggi sei una madre urbani
che galleggiano è non accetta mai solo
per questa volta andrò ad accettare
i miei pop
e c'è un problema io ho finito i nuovi
pop hit quindi gli unici che mi
rimangono solo quelli che ho scambiato
tutti li offro e il dinosauro è la
regola granchi
ma quelli sono i pop hit che ho appena
scambiato con te non mi interessano come
vogliono nuovi pochi nuove cose i nuovi
bobbito sono questi che appena scambiato
ti ricordi che li ho persi tutti aspetta
però ho un'idea o una cosa da offrirti
per cui dovrei pagare tante come il
papeete però perché è molto speciale
sentiamo che cosa mi offrì resti allora
il mio iphone
allora quanti pop hit mi offre per
questo vale tantissimi pop hit quindi ne
deve offrire tantissimi è molto
prezioso il tuo iphone
ma sei sicuro city almeno recupererò
tutti i miei compiti che cosa mi offrano
artisti di tantissimi vediamo che noi
mettiamo un lama un po la spirale punto
da sole poi abbiamo anche uno perché
cambia colore si illumina perché va bene
che abbia valore il pavimento un pezzo
foto dello no poi ci mette una bella
aspettiamo un limone un car che con i
corni miniatura perfetto quello al cobà
loro nel suo anche quello verde di
dinosauro guarda quanti pochi sono
adesso devi accettare
non sono abbastanza per un iphone quindi
di
non sono abbastanza per questo questi
sono i viola testa uffa allora vediamo
aggiungo un avvocato gigante e maturo è
buono
aggiungo ubik sheikh di pili e aggiungo
un buffetto in più
un gattino multicolor e ora cosa per il
telefono insomma questa nomi potrebbe
servire io voglio voglio fare la festa
si è perché sta dando tutte le forme è
che ti serve la cover del treno in
viaggio bellissimo ha capito dei bitumi
dei tre vuoi la cover
questa sarà l'ultima offerta però è se
non accetti il ritiro tutto
ieri purtroppo quella cover ma volevo
anche nell'altra sala in se vi ricordate
beh direi che ora i pocket sono
abbastanza c'è anche quella bellissima
cover
vi starete chiedendo cosa te ne stai
della cover senza cellulare
ebbene
sì
io tutti noi
[Musica]
evviva ora sono in vantaggio sono io
quella che ha più pochi talento e
soprattutto questa bellissima cover pop
hit che bella
[Musica]
ma mi stai prendendo in giro dov'è il
telefono e titolo vedi
questa mi sembra un ananas e ananas
e di pace lamela è invece tu hai lana la
del telefono
chimica canto non ho mai detto che avrei
messo realmente un vero telefono dentro
e rendono la statale dentro c'era anche
il capitano
troppo divertente ma come il telefono
dai io volevo il telefono vero ridarmi
tutti i botti tedesco ormai accettato
pronto pronto polizia abbia rubato i
morti
non funzionano ma c'è aiuto a polizia
gli ruba di bofill pronto troppo basso
si passo passo silva o passati pochezza
di sorprese capi dietro polizia bene ora
che ho tenuto la cover che volevo
proviamo
il mondo intero come promesso wow
bellissima la carpa bit
wow oh wow mentre chiamo posto
schiacciare i pochi
e ben lei però ecco perché volevi la
cover ci avrebbe dovuto pensare prima
era una tavola che mi sta riprendendo
bene ma mi dispiace per te è troppo
tardi si o no quasi finito tutti i pochi
devo trovare una soluzione per
riprendermelo un po indietro di tutti
quelli che ti ho dato da bensì di
offrire ti offrirò
questa il intendo switch e è quello vero
vero quello vero certo che è quello vero
io differenza tua non metto la scatola
detto lo switch ovvero guarda lo voglio
assolutamente quindi ti offro una
montagna di koh pich per il nintendo
suite allora accetti per racconti toro o
una montagna di pompei ma lo switch vale
di più quindi più e va bene un altra
montagna di pop hit
guarda che alta ora la montagna è
aspettare devo cercare di non farla
cadere e cubature che bella montagna di
pochi allora accetti giuliano montagna
sembra una torre fino a jackie di più ma
va bene ti offro anche il pop il gigante
che mi hai dato tutto e che grande e
bellissimo
tutto in equilibrio
allora accetti la suite vale di più
quindi di più mi rimangono pochissimi
pupi so io come fare con vitale e il
cibo
io probabile avocado e poi un pick up
che che poi un caso perdono ti piace
profit limone allora al
cibo
la questione diventa interessante ma gpu
a come di più questi sono tutti bobbit
che mi rimangono se ti do questi popoli
sono quelle rivali anche uno che non
accetti con questi non posso più
offrirti nessun pop hit nella cover ma
non te ne fai niente perché non è il
cellulare quindi queste sono gli ultimi
pop hit che ti offro
tv per forza accettare lo gnu altri
quanti poveri
non vuoi non accettare quindi
praticamente mi hai dato tutti i pop hit
che hai vinto da me
certo
[Musica]
tutti miei
prendi pure assenza non far cadere la
corretta
ciao a tutti i miei faccio meno rivolto
verso
tutti i miei
li ho ripresi tutti i miei pochi tappa
ea vivaio la mia suite proviamolo subito
e
e ma
non c'e nessun gioco qua non posso
giocare a niente
tu vedessi giochi
ti ho fregato io questa volta è come
dici tu è vero che è vinto la suite ma è
anche vero che non hai vinto i giochi
quindi ai la suite senso giochi o no
dove infarti prima io adesso sono
nuovamente tenta pop hit con una
principessa giochi e la cover per il
cellulare o vi ho dato vitale anche i
nuovi pocket che avevo comprato
sono riuscito a riprendermi tutti i pop
hit che ti offerto più hip hop it rari
che hai preso tu quindi per la prossima
chance dovrai diciamo trovare tante cose
nuove per potervi convincere a dare in
cambio altri botti voi avreste scambiato
tutti bobby tuber la suite
scrivetelo nei commenti
e lasciate un mi piace così possiamo
avere una rivincita e possa finalmente a
riprendermi un po di bob ne so che mi
piace qua e ora vi lasciamo 4 caselline
tu puoi cliccare per vedere inoltre
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite